- Oh, wow.
This is hitting something in me
that I've never felt before,
and it's kind of insane.
(whooshing)
(squeaking)
(groovy music)
- Today, we are trying
weird massage products
that you can buy on Amazon.
- I've never gotten a massage in my life.
- I actually love massages.
- I get a massage probably once a month.
It's like my self-care routine.
- I have very tense shoulders.
- My shoulders just feel really gross.
I just feel sore all the time.
- I don't know if this
is gonna be really weird,
or if these are actually
gonna be good products,
so we're gonna have to see.
(relaxing music)
- Okay.
I definitely thought this was a Bop It.
- It looks like one of those little things
that you do math on.
- This is like
one of these things.
- Maybe it's for your neck or something?
Like this?
- Just feels like I'm kinda
making pizza out of my thigh.
- Okay, I see what's happening here.
You got me.
You got me real good.
- It does feel good.
Oh, I think that's what it is.
You need to flex your
muscle while you do it.
- This is good too.
Okay.
- Yeah, it loosens up your muscles.
It's good.
(relaxing music)
- Oh, it's a little hand massager.
This is so cute.
- This looks like a alien or something.
- Got some little cool roly balls.
- Okay, so I'm guessing
you put your hand inside
like so, and you bring it up to you,
and you just go at it.
- It just feels like I'm running some
Hot Wheels cars on my legs.
- I feel like you could shower with this.
Put a little soap on these balls.
- I would love this if
somebody used it on me.
I don't necessarily need
to use it on somebody else.
I'm selfish.
- Oh yeah, that's kinda nice.
But that's 'cause you're doing it for me.
I would definitely buy this,
but I would also need a boyfriend too.
(relaxing music)
- Okay, first and foremost.
Trigger, trigger therapy massager?
- Look at these instructions.
I hate reading instructions.
- Okay, that's interesting.
Let's try the other side.
- What the hell?
Okay.
What?
What is this?
- Okay.
It feels nice.
I like, ooh that's good right there.
Ouch.
- This looks like a contraption
that you kill somebody with.
(laughing)
- This isn't effective.
Nothing, nothing about this.
- I'm just gonna fuck that
and just do my own thing.
Ooh.
- You just have all these
little pressure points,
little bumps that you
apply to pressure points,
and get rid of any knots you have.
- If this feels good to you,
just fuckin' use an umbrella.
(relaxing music)
- Is this for my butt?
- Left cheek, right cheek, no?
- This is gettin' high tech.
- Okay, whoever has used this already,
there's oil spots, so I feel
like they put their face on it.
- What do I do with this?
Like this?
- Oh snap!
Look at this!
There's like four little
planets moving inside.
- This is so hypnotic.
Anyway, I'm gonna put it on my ass now.
- This feels kinda nice.
- Okay, let's try that.
All right.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh,
oh, okay, okay.
- Okay, oh wow.
I don't know.
My lower back!
- Oh man, it's gettin' nooks and crannies
I forgot about.
Oh snap!
- I don't know, I just feel like
someone would definitely call HR
if I was constantly using this at my desk.
- I feel like I need privacy, honestly.
I feel like I'm havin' a moment.
- If this isn't that expensive,
this is almost as good as a massage chair.
(relaxing music)
- This thing looks like a cast
member of Stranger Things.
I don't know what's happening.
- This is somethin'.
- This is intense.
- Hello?
Yes.
Karen, is that you?
- Oh, okay.
All right, let's go.
Woo-hoo.
Oh snap!
- It's kind of rough,
but I kind of like it.
(laughing)
(motor grinding)
- Okay, chill, chill, chill, chill.
- Oh snap!
(vocalizing)
- I think this is for your vocal chords.
- You don't even need anyone.
You can be alone for the rest of your life
if you have this.
- If I had it plugged in,
next to my bed, just at
night, before I go to bed.
- I think I just found a
new best friend, y'all.
- The only issue about this
machine, is it's really loud.
So if you have roommates or parents,
everyone's gonna know you're goin' at it
as soon as you turn this on.
They're like, "Ah,
Erick's massaging again."
- Honestly, after trying all
of these massage products,
I feel a lot more stressed out.
I feel really anxious.
- I feel really relaxed right now.
I can go take a nap.
- My favorite is that
little ghost hand thing.
Or that little alien looking thing.
- The last two are the
one that were the best.
- My favorite one was that butt one.
Not for my butt, although once in a while.
- It really did help.
I'm not even,
that was really great.
- Whatever, I'll try anything once.
- Still go get some massages,
but these are okay to hold you over
till your next one.
- The things the internet can do.
It's incredible.
(relaxing music)
(whooshing)
(squeaking)